-Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
Guys, it is that time
of year again.
Tomorrow is Santacon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Here in New York City,
thousands of people
will dress up as Santa
and pack the streets
for an all-day bar crawl.
Yep.
[ Laughter ]
Things kick off in Midtown
at 10 a.m.
and then end asleep
on a sidewalk,
spooning a trash bag
at 2 p.m..
So you're gonna want
to wake the kids
for that one.
That's right.
Thousands in Midtown
will be dressed in red suits
and begin drinking
at 10 a.m.
Right now, Times Square Elmo is
like, "Oh, sure,
but when I do it..."
Some political news tonight.
President Biden was in LA
for a campaign fundraiser
with Steven Spielberg.
Yeah, Biden knows
Spielberg's work well.
Anytime his staff
brings his poll numbers,
he hears the theme from "Jaws."
Of course,
because it's Hollywood.
Biden won't admit his approval
rating is shrinking.
He just says
it's on Ozempic.
Speaking of Biden,
earlier today,
he announced
the largest investment
in passenger rail transportation
since the creation of Amtrak.
The largest investment
since the creation of Amtrak,
which is big for Biden
because he was there
for the creation of the wheel.
Yeah, Biden just announced
a massive new rail investment,
and we actually got
our hands on the message
Biden recorded that
they're playing on every train
in the country
starting today.
Yeah. Check this out.
-I think that's fantastic.
What?
Come on.
-Pocket full of salamanders?
-Yeah. Pocket full
of salamanders. That's right.
Well, people are talking
about this.
Last night, Hunter Biden was
indicted on nine tax charges.
Yeah, in a 56-page indictment,
he's accused of dodging
federal taxes,
making false payments
on Venmo, and fraud.
Well, when asked
how he feels about Hunter
not paying his taxes,
President Biden said
it is very disappointing.
While former President
Trump said...
Next, when asked how he feels
about Hunter Venmoing
$1,500 to an exotic dancer,
President Biden
said it's irresponsible,
while Trump said...
And finally, when asked if
he'd consider pardoning Hunter,
President Biden said no.
Trump said...
-What? Wow.
-Some news from overseas.
I saw that Vladimir Putin
announced
that he's running
for president of Russia again.
Wow. I don't want to say
their elections are phony,
but on their "I voted" stickers,
the word "voted" is in quotes.
Some business news --
Krispy Kreme just opened their
first French location in Paris.
Finally, a place to get
decent pastry in Paris.
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this?
Pantone just announced
their 2024 color of the year
is Peach Fuzz.
Yeah. Can we see
a picture of Peach Fuzz?
Hey, that's why I --
Come on! Hey!
Hey, why --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey.
-Uh, well, this is wild.
Authorities at an airport
in Thailand
caught a man smuggling
two otters
and a prairie dog
in his pants.
Not much you can really do
after that other than yell,
"Ta da!"
I mean, really?
Well, get this. I read about
a couple in Florida
who got married while
going through a car wash.
Good thing about getting
married in a car wash
is that the 10th one's free.
-Finally, guys,
we have exactly 11 shows left
before we go
on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters.
-♪ 12 days of Christmas
sweaters ♪
♪ 11 days left ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
Every show between now
and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a bodacious
Christmas sweater
from the countdown
to Christmas cabinet.
Since there are 11 shows left,
let's open door number 11.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's nice.
Thank you very much.
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
I need you to jump up
and let me know where you are
if you get --
if I say your number.
Quest,
can I get a drum roll, please?
Who wants me
to pick their number?
This is good.
♪♪
-448.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright. Oh, man.
Here we go.
We can do a little --
Come over here. Gosh.
How are you? Barely made it
on the standby line there, huh?
Uh, you don't want to come down
one step towards me? Come on.
Gosh, I just walked up --
How you doing?
-Hi. Hi, I'm Mark.
-Oh, what is --
-What is your name?
-Mark.
-Yeah. Uh, Mark,
where are you from?
-I'm from Spain.
-Hey.
Welcome.
Thank you for being here.
Mark, it gets a little chilly
sometimes in Spain, correct?
-Yeah. It is.
-Yeah. Cold.
Right? I mean, you have this.
This is very nice.
I love this fleece.
Whatever it is, it's gorgeous.
Do you have anything like this?
-No, I don't, I don't, I don't.
-Have you ever seen
anything like this?
-No.
-No, never.
Would you like to try it on?
-Yeah, sure.
-Yeah, I think you should.
You can put it over that.
I want to make it
as uncomfortable as possible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And this is the front.
This is the front, I think.
The good thing
about this sweater
is there's no front or back.
You just put it on and hope
for the best, you know?
Oh, this is great, Mark.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. That's right.
Oh, wow. He made it through.
He made it through.
Look at that.
That looks fantastic.
Look at how good you look.
Fantastic, buddy.
-Thank you.
-Welcome.
Thank you for being here. Enjoy.
Happy holidays, buddy.
-Thank you.
-Give it up for Mark, everybody.
Stick around.
When we come back,
we're doing something fun
with Anne Hathaway.